the Center for American Progress is
Moscow project has now revealed that the
Trump campaign and Trump transition team
members had more than a hundred contacts
with Russia linked officials and in the
last couple of weeks we've learned about
some of the deeper ties we're starting
to see how it all fits together the
Russian lawyers Russian intelligence
people Kremlin linked businessmen it's
sort of a full slate cast of characters
but what is now clear is that when you
sort of step back a little bit and
consider contacts in general this was
not casual contact between the Trump
administration and Russians right it
wasn't well there was some casual
contact with people who happen to be
Russian and casual contacts with the
Chinese and casual contacts with the
Japanese and casual contacts with
Chileans all throughout the campaign
because they were merely running a
campaign and happened to have contact
with people from all over the world the
foreign contacts are heavily
concentrated operationally around
individuals from or linked to one
country and that is Russia once you
establish that you then have to figure
out what was the purpose of the contacts
what were the ends that were achieved by
virtue of having those contacts and
that's what Robert Muller is now doing
in his investigation the point I've been
making is one that is made in this
Moscow report by the Center for American
Progress over 100 contacts with Russians
matters because in running a
presidential campaign you don't have 100
contacts with one foreign power if
you're not coordinating anything and if
there isn't something extensive going on
there period there's another important
point here these are 100 contacts that
are publicly knowable by going through
all of the documents and various court
filings about this who knows how many
there could actually be that we haven't
learned about yet because there's not
public information about and we should
assume that there are more than just the
ones that have gone public thus far and
the types of contacts that this includes
are any contact by a trump associate
with individuals known to have ties to
Russian President Vladimir Putin himself
or to Russian intelligence bank
and politicians and remember that
Russian banks are relevant since in
Russia many are effectively part of the
government although not officially in
the legal sense as an example the number
100 was the number a couple of days ago
until we now learned that convinced
convicted Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort shared campaign polling data
with Russian business partner Konstantin
kill Nick that now makes the number a
hundred and one and at this point I feel
it necessary to repeat this sort of key
point this is the most conservative
assessment of the number of contacts 101
because number one it consists only of
contacts that are publicly known they've
appeared in public documents including
court filings and number two it is only
contacts that we can identify and direct
if there were Trump people meeting with
cut outs for Russian government
officials or bankers or influencers
those wouldn't be included in this list
in terms of who was doing the contacting
some of the usual suspects are on the
list Michael Cohen we know about Roger
stone we know about Donald Trump jr.
Carter Page Michael Flynn but then there
are some other interesting names Ivanka
Trump we don't really yet know the full
extent of her contacts with Russian
linked individuals Anthony scaramouche
II I would have been less sure that
scaramouche II was involved in this
stuff himself Jeff Sessions of course
claimed under oath during a hearing that
he had no contact then ended up having
to recuse himself on all Russia related
matters for the remainder of his tenure
as attorney general because that simply
wasn't true so the bottom line on this
is number one it's not surprising number
two the real number is obviously way
higher than 101 and number three I hope
that some day this matters that's really
the most important thing because the
biggest coup of this atrocity for the
Trump administration is that if Obama
had done a fraction of this the right
would be rioting in the streets
demanding that he stepped down I'm not
saying the left is better for not riding
in the streets maybe the left is busy
working and living their lives maybe
riding in the streets is not what they
feel would actually bring Khan
secuence as to what it is that Donald
Trump has done but it could be the right
thing to be doing to be rioting in the
streets and demanding that Trump step
down but the question mark that remains
is will there be consequences for any of
this stuff because if there isn't this
would be an amazing victory for the
Trump campaign and transition team
having this degree of contact this
degree of criminality and ultimately
getting out of it with yes some people
indicted and convicted in doing some
nominal amount of time in prison but big
picture not with major consequences I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com
forward slash PA que ma n